good evening and welcome to the San
Francisco Public Library I'm Kendall one
the city librarian for the City and
County of San Francisco we are
privileged this evening
to have with us the author and
journalist Jessica Mitford who has
agreed to speak in honor of our prides
and Joy's exhibition a showcase of the
special treasures of the San Francisco
Public Library I invite all of you to
visit our exhibition which will run
through November the 30th which is on
the first floor the second floor and the
third floor of the library a self termed
didactic Jessica Mitford has spent most
of her writing career in search of
worthy targets for expose following her
first major success in 1963 with the
publication of the American Way of death
she was dubbed queen of the muckrakers
by the Time magazine she has published
many articles in books since that time
including kind and unusual punishment
the American prison business in 1973 a
final conflict in 1977 Reason penmanship
the gentle heart of muckraking in 1979
and grace had an English heart in 1988
her latest work which she was sharing
with us what she's working on the
American Way of birth is scheduled to be
published in 1992 by penguin this
evening miss Mitford will speak on and I
really love this title sex and the First
Amendment porn bashers from Jesse Helms
to Andrea Dworkin ladies and gentlemen
please join me in welcoming
Jessica
well this is an enormous pleasure for me
especially seeing all of you I can't
believe it I thought but but five people
would show up very exciting and I'm
thrilled to be here I just wanted to
tell you so say a little background to
this talk this evening
recently I was scheduled to speak in
Hattiesburg Mississippi not too far from
Tupelo Mississippi where the Reverend
Donald Wildmon has his influential
headquarters you probably read all about
his attack on a segment of the LA law
television program headlined in the San
Francisco Chronicle as the media fallout
from the lesbian kiss the point being
that two female attorneys was seen
kissing on-screen the kissing question
took place in a parking lot first a
quick goodbye smooch followed by a
longer more lingering kiss thereupon
Reverend wild mom sprung into action
with an effort to ban LA law off the air
so when I got to had his Berg
Mississippi I've asked the college to
send him a special invitation to my
lecture I thought it'd be um she
actually thought the subject were really
appealed to him sex in the First
Amendment both of which he deplores he
thought that he hate sex
it's the First Amendment so I got there
he didn't come to my great sorrow and I
cut called out shouted out to the
audience of approximately a thousand
people
Reverend Wilde mom over don't say you
stood me up you know that sort of thing
begging him to come up that's it if
you're there please come up to the mic
and we can have the most special debate
and so on you know but he never showed I
was head over that but never mind as an
introduction to Reverend Wilde mom and
his overriding preoccupation here are a
couple of verses from Philip Larkins
poem annus mirabilis it starts off like
this
sexual intercourse began in 1963 which
was rather late for me between the end
of the Taliban and the Beatles first LP
up to then that only been a sort of
bargaining a wrangle for a ring a shame
that started at sixteen and spread to
everything
then all once the quarrel sank everyone
felt the same and every life became a
brilliant breaking of the bank a quite
unusable game so life was never better
than in 1963 they're just too late for
me between the end of the cella ban and
the beatles first LP philip larkin so
perhaps 1963 was when the Reverend
Donald Wildmon also discovered sexual
intercourse and the potential money fame
and acclaimed to be garnered from
deploring it wherever it raised his ugly
head either in books magazines movies
and above all in television plays I
first became aware of him many years ago
when he tried and almost succeeded to
have my angeles and television plays
sisters a star-studded performance
featuring Diahann Carroll cisely Tyson
and others taken off the air his method
is simple
he created a huge and
growing membership of right-wing
fundamentalists in his organization
called the American Family Association
if he wants a production band he calls
on these to send letters to not the
television network no but to the
commercial sponsors urging them to
withdraw sponsorship or face of mass
boycott of their products money being as
he above all should know the root of all
evil
this is a singularly successful tactic
it was beaten down in the case of
sisters by a large effort of the black
community plus assaulted friends and
fans of all over the country of Maya
Angelou so that that's just a little
sort of thing about him you know as you
can see is an interesting man and one
wishes one could meet it Monday
the sisters episode was actually some
years ago long before the name and fame
of Reverend wildmen was known throughout
the land today you've been hard to pick
up any cultural page of the newspaper
without reading about him in the
headlines for example item wild Hmong
reps lia sitcom sight unseen that's a
headline this the story tells us that
Riven wild mon hasn't actually seen the
show which was called sunday dinner
but his grousing is its anti-christian
and has sent word to his 675 thousand
people on his mailing list to discourage
advertisers from supporting it another
item and the NEA granted film targeted
sorry an NEA meaning the National
Endowment of the Arts film targeted by
Wilde mom the film is poison in which
Wilde montages the National Endowment of
the Arts with funding a movie that
portrays homosexual sex now his
considerable political clout is enormous
he contributed vast sums to senator
Jesse Helms is successful senatorial
campaign again these two are made for
each other and absolute birds of a
feather when it comes to such matters as
the National Endowment of the Arts so
much for them the aspect of censorship
that I want to discuss is when and how
it became a deeply divisive issue in the
women's movement
an interesting spin-off actually of the
wholly admirable and often successful
efforts of the feminist movement to
change public and judicial attitudes to
the crime of rape hitherto often blamed
on the victim and not on the aggressor
is the split developing in the women's
movement on the question of censorship
of pornography the argument in favor of
banning hustla penthouse etcetera is
that men read these magazines and then
rush out to rape but in some circles I'm
thinking particularly at the National
Lawyers Guild the local branch of it the
Bay Area National Lawyers Guild there
was a tremendous growl going on there
brouhaha among the women lawyers
particularly taking sides on this
question according to one participant
controversy has become so heated that it
seemed to be changing rapidly from
debate to feud and the centered on
proposed anti-pornography statutes the
the arguments pro and con was set forth
in the National Lawyers Guild
anti-sexism newsletter which ii gave you
know kind of rundown on the on the
points of view for example it said i'm
quoting from the newsletter the statutes
proponents argue that an absolutist
defense of the First Amendment obscures
the social reality of men's power over
women who are targets a sexual coercion
and discrimination that pornography
promotes another pornography
institutionalizes the sexuality of male
supremacy another anti porn statutes can
give women new and needed power to make
visible those injuries which pornography
promotes and to articulate and resist
sexist domination the debate is brought
to the fore all kinds of extreme
viewpoints for example Andrea Dworkin
who seems to think that all men are
wrists at heart here are a few of her
observations quoting from Andrea Dworkin
for men the right to abuse women is
elemental the first principle with no
beginning and with no end plausibly in
sight pornography is the holy corpus of
men who would rather die than change
pornography reveals that male pleasure
is inextricably tied to victimizing
hurting exploiting the sexual fun and
sexual passion in the privacy of the
male imagination are inseparable from
the brutality of male history that's a
bit of a mouthful but anyhow since then
Andrea Dworkin has published other
material notably a book called starkly
intercourse in which she States
unequivocally
that all forms of heterosexual
intercourse are rape so she and like
mine a like-minded colleague Catherine
MacKinnon a law professor passed the
most sweeping anti-pornography ordinance
in American history in alliance with the
conservative City Council of Minea
Minneapolis it was struck down by the
courts but the spirit behind it is still
alive and well those against legislation
to ban pornography point out that there
is no proof of any causal relationship
between pornography and violence against
women they give the example of Amsterdam
capital of porn where you can't walk
downtown I hear I've never actually been
there but we are told you have walked
down to how without being assaulted on
every side I filled the absolutely
revolting movie marquees offering
everything the most rotten heart could
desire in the way of dirty films and sex
shops with God knows what for sale porn
book shops and so on yet Amsterdam
claims to be freer of the crimes of
assault against women than any Western
city why one theory is
that would be rapists act out their
fantasies by watching the dirty movies
and reading the dirty books I don't
pretend to know if this is true it has
to me is old spurious sounding logic
possibly dreamed up by the Amsterdam
Chamber of Commerce and but for the
argument against legislation to ban
pornography I'd like to read from a
letter by the rent France in the same
publication of the National Lawyers
Guild and here's what he has to say he
said the new drive against pornography
is supposed to be about violence and
coercion yet already it is being argued
that to punish the picture of a nude
woman is to feed her body is an object
and thereby to encourage rape so with
the campaign scarcely begun the target
has already expanded from violence to
mere nudity and that is only the
beginning these things are governed by a
general law which might be formulated as
follows if X quality is deemed to
justify suppression then people who wish
to suppress something will discover that
it has X quality as the campaign
progresses moral majoritarian x'
right-to-lifers Homo phobes sex Oh
phobes prudes and others engaged in
supervising other people's morals will
find pornography wherever it suits their
purpose to find it and you can no more
stop them than you could stop
Regan from fighting communism in any
third world government or movement that
he might have wished to murder how many
times do we have to relearn the lesson
that freedom is indivisible and
continually was the letter for rent
France said I'm in favor of doing
something about violence against women
there are plenty of white wifebeaters
out there as well as quite a few rapists
going after people who have used
violence instead of after pornography
has the advantage that it does not
require us to toss out the window the
freedom to deal with sex in literature
and art which cost generations of
struggle to achieve take a group
reading is that I was thinking to the
you know about the the portrayal of
nudes what about the Sistine Chapel and
they on the ceiling theirs there's
adorable looking cherubs naked children
you know I'm they're the kind of thing
that that would be prosecuted under the
sort of law that that the the people
like Andrea Dworkin the supporting
anyway I thought that Loretta Francis
letter to the Lawyers Guild bulletin was
absolutely on target I mean has anyone
thought back to the trial of Lady
Chatterley's Lover the book that is I
mean not the lover in which the
prosecutor cautioned the jurors but
surely they would agree the one wouldn't
want one's children or servants to read
such a book upon which somewhere grew
marked and certainly not once gamekeeper
well if everybody's reflected on the
implications of the rape of Lucrece I
William Shakespeare which might easily
inspire some modern-day Tarquin to go
forth and do the same what about the
Holy Bible which is full of s and V but
a jolly good read nevertheless or the
Kinsey Report which as I recall had
fascinating tabulated data on the sexual
habits of American males for me the most
intriguing revelation in this catalogue
was that one out of every eight American
men has had intercourse with animals so
you know I mean attended a hunch party I
couldn't help glancing round I've tried
to get so much which what one of the
eight present have done it and and with
whom I'm in man's best friend
or sheep or a horse the report was
rather disappointingly reticent on this
score but I wonder whether the animal
rights advocates are being horrified
about this is it not possible their
reader the Kinzua report might become so
titillated as to have a go with the pig
just to see what it's like does for a
brief parenthetical detour to illustrate
how easy it is to stray unwittingly from
the part of that path of virtual
righteousness and must just tell about a
correspondence between my sister Nancy
and our aunt iris one of the
prototypical maiden ants of all time she
was born in about ninety about 1880 died
at the age of ninety having lived a
chaste and made mountain Antley life now
Nancy for some reason had a great liking
for moles because moles crucial were
part of our family coat of arms so all
her work books in which she wrote her
novels and so on had Mills engraved on
them and one day she got some lovely
writing paper with a golden mole on it
printed so she wrote on this paper to
aunt iris who wrote back I loved your
writing paper with the pretty little
mole when I was a girl the local people
in Gloucestershire called them [ __ ] and
she said of course you one never hears
that word anymore
so Nancy wrote to me saying obvious if
she's not part of the Kenneth Tynan set
I think actually that the the radical
feminist porn batters would do well to
reflect on the motives of their strange
bedfellows on the far right
for example the moral majority in a
whole number of suck the states mostly
southern who've zeroed in on Maya
Angelou's book I Know Why the Caged Bird
Sings and on Alice Walker's Prize
winning color purple for their allegedly
pure prurient content actually Sethe to
me it seems like a thinly disguised
effort to do in these best-selling black
authors along with such a tried and true
targets as JD Salinger Kurt Vonnegut and
Miss magazine I have a large
correspondence with people in Alabama
and so on about this and in each case
the librarians were on the front line
and succeeded in frustrating the would
be banners that's one reason why I love
speaking in a library and very often and
my favorite audience do can be you know
librarians because they usually on the
front line of their see now for a couple
of personal experiences I don't know
whether any of you have ever met a moral
majority perhaps not I mean they don't
list exist around here to effort well I
have on a couple of occasions I found it
a sort of amusing experience not without
its comic aspects a few years ago I was
on a lecture tour of the South one stop
being at the ohoopee Public Library in
Vidalia Georgia Vidalia is a tiny town
of a population about twelve thousand is
so small that even people in Savannah a
hundred miles away of never heard of
the ohoopee Public Library was having a
symposium on deaf which is very big
these days on college campuses Library
Association's etc so these Deathly
meetings were scheduled on successive
Tuesdays to be addressed by ministers on
religious aspects philosophers etc and I
was the leadoff speaker on the death
industry's broadhead I suppose you know
as a bit of comic relief I'm not sure
but then the American Legion attacked
they blasted the O Hoopoe public library
for giving a platform to a well known
subversive and they sent copies of all
the old house on American Activities
Committee reports on me to the
newspapers so the Savannah papers now
sort of sprang into life and they
carried all these releases but the
librarians fought back and with First
Amendment rights everybody can have his
or her say the ohoopee Public Library
they said and they also had the clever
idea of sending special invitations for
with free tickets to the lecture to the
funeral directors or from miles around
and the allied industries you know
underlining the free speech message and
urging them to come so as a result of
this totally unexpected publicity which
sort of covered the area around vidalia
and Savannah the the the lecture had to
be moved from the small meeting hall
where it was said supposed to be to the
high school auditorium which was
absolutely packed so the Chairman led
off repeating the free speech stand at
the library and he asked are there any
members of the funeral profession here
upon which 12 black suits stood up all
in a row
then they said done so I gave my talk
which seemed to be quite well-received
because most people in Vidalia is
elsewhere have at one time or another
suffered from the masa nations of the
funeral industry but in the question
period following the lead of the
introducer the Chairman I first asked
whether there were any questions from
the funeral contingent so a black suit
rose up and he said I am a vault man
I sell vaults I know my southern accent
isn't very good what he was saying is I
am a fault man I sell vaults funeral
vaults I listen to Miss Mitford speech
and she never said that when Jesus
Christ our Lord was crucified a rich man
gave him his vault
they said done so I replied that as I
spent a lot of time in motels whether
the only reading supply directory is the
Bible I was indeed familiar with the
story of Joseph of Arimathea and his
gift to Jesus of his fault but then if
you read on father
it seems that Jesus didn't stay there
all that long
yeah I mean he was up and out in three
days at this point the black the black
suits all rose up the whole 12 of them
and said let's go and they walked out I
was expecting people to follow I mean
you know because after all we're in the
Bible Belt deep Bible Belt in Vidalia
Georgia and it runs my pleasure
not a soul stirred they all stayed and
told state they were brothel keen to
discuss their mother's funeral that kind
of thing people are and so it was
actually rather a triumph I thought and
in a way you know so another encounter a
recent one with the moral majority was
really huge Conclave of librarians in
Idaho it was a three-day affair with
perhaps 2,000 librarians from all over
the western states in attendance during
the proceedings
I found myself up on a platform as part
of a panel on censorship with several
librarians and a representative
self-declared of the moral majority a
clean-cut young fellow aged about 30
name of Michael Faris who was a lawyer
from the state of Washington some of the
librarians had told me earlier watch out
for him he's very intelligent very
ambitious and he may soon be a
congressman or who knows maybe the
President of the United States one day
something no anyhow the main target of
Michael Pharisees talk was booked called
Our Bodies Ourselves
which of course was a tremendous
bestseller and has been for years and
years so mr. pharisee was explaining to
the audience that he has three little
daughters the oldest a six-year-old is
brilliant he said and she goes to the
library by herself and she is a great
reader he does not want her to find this
book
to be exposed to the explicit sexual
material therein so he's bringing a
lawsuit to have it banned from the
library
so the librarians on the panel fought
back valiantly and at length they cited
the First Amendment they spoke of the
danger of any form of censorship and
where it could lead
well luckily for me I happen to have on
me a mailing from the Reverend Jerry
Falwell mr. Pharisees guru on the
envelope was stamped adults-only which I
thought was surely an invitation to any
child worth it solved it open Reverend
for was letter with a curious document
to me reminiscent of my FBI file which I
finally pried loose out of the FEMA
Freedom of Information Act these FBI
documents as some of you have not miss
noticed if you sent for your own
dossiers a full of blanks they say
subject seemed talking to blank and
that's a blank tile or subject sealed
entering blank and so on the third balls
with Reverend falls letter and his heed
blank out all the dirty words with
equally curious effect from Our Bodies
Ourselves
Reverend for were quoted as we as our
bodies moved to the music I could feel
his blank and his blank pressing on me
well I said to the librarians no wonder
mr. Ferris doesn't want his six-year-old
to read this book a chat with two of
those
she'd be deeply disappointed in later
life to discover that is strictly one to
a customer
I'd love to have some discussion
questions everything else this
microphone and distribute it right here
Jessica you said that the freedom is
indivisible do you make exceptions with
the expression of child pornography yeah
no I wouldn't make any exceptions at all
I mean I would certainly make every
exception to an assault exploitation of
children like you the something you read
about you know or exploitation of
anybody for the sake of a movie but
that's a different question from from
most known as child pornography which
can cover a huge spectrum nonsensical
stuff including a photographs of naked
children that sort of thing you know
that's not pornography in my view so in
other words if a child is forced into a
situation where it were boy or girl has
to perform sex acts is forced to do that
well of course I'd be against that but
that's not the quit that's not the same
thing that's actions against a child you
know it's not the poor it's not poor
trails of things do you get the
difference I think you can find
consensual children I think you can find
consensual children to have our sexual
experiences and consent to being
photographed would this be an exception
that you would approve or we bet you
would accept well I think is very
difficult to answer these hypothetical
things without knowing far more about
the situation I mean if you knew of
something where the Lord been broken in
in the sense of compelling a child to do
something well I think that that
be another matter that would be my view
my understanding from feminists I
respect who are opposed to pornography
involving women is that it it fosters
the links give me the attitude that
since most pornography involving women
is involves women who are young and thin
and able-bodied and blemish-free etc etc
that it fosters the attitude that if you
are not all of those things you are not
attractive you're not sexy you're you're
less than fully valuable and well those
people may still say that censorship is
worse their attitude is that that stuff
keeps us going as a culture in the
direction of objectifying women that
these women are not in these magazines
because they have fascinating hobbies
and they're highly intellectual they're
there for their bodies this is not my
point of view but I'm playing devil's
advocate a little here well my feeling
about that would be that the same thing
goes back to Shakespeare oh I don't have
far in other words the take the
Midsummer Night's Dream the characters
in there both men and women are
obviously sort of young attractive
interesting fascinating people right you
know and so and it's a it's love stories
about these couples and so I can't see
anything wrong with that in other words
and I certainly think that that the
converse idea you know we're sort of a
deeply thought through novels have taken
taken through somebody's life you know
that kind of thing there are also
extremely important but I can't think
how banning these books movies or
what-have-you and magazines is going to
help anything by the way I mean nobody
is compelled to read them you can just
leave them alone I
sorry to tell you that I don't think
I've ever actually read a copy of them
hustler and keep meaning to get one but
let us see what they've got but I have a
terrible feeling I might be bored it was
a condition I don't like but I think
that for anyone who wants them they
should be absolutely free to have them
yeah I'd like to I make my living in the
adult video business and while it may be
true that many of the women who make the
movies are indeed young and beautiful
that's the way it is in all of American
advertising and Hollywood is just there
around it so in that way adult material
does reflect what's happening in the
culture but there is actually a wider
range of acceptable body type for adult
material then there is four straight
modeling or straight advertising and
most of it the only difference is we
show two little bits of flesh and the
advertising industry make sure that
these things are covered up and we still
not going to see a pubic hair in Vanity
Fair magazine almost but not quite
my desire would be to have more women or
differently-abled people make their own
material that speaks to their own
experience and find ways to distribute
it because there are too few people who
do make it and their vision is very
narrow the vision needs to be expanded
the only way we can do that of course is
to make it ourselves
in light of the Thomas Hill hearings I
was so curious because I lived in Europe
of what the Europeans thought of this
whole circus that was going on and the
shame of America felt and all of that
and I finally heard a journalist respond
from Belgium I believe it was and he
said how hypocritical it is of you
Americans your your feminists want all
this you know equality with men and all
that and here you're it's it's
hypocritical you're raising Cain because
a woman might even be pinched to me I
guess he meant that the European view is
even women have made more headway in
Europe and they're still very feminine
quote-unquote that is men that's right
they exist what do you think of that by
the way I have just got a whole bunch of
clippings on this very subject from the
London Times and other English
newspapers you know and they did be kind
of confused and puzzled over it cause my
own view is that number one long before
Anita Hill came on the scene those
senators you know should have absolutely
decided to check this fellow over
because he was a liar and unqualified
and many other things do you say there
when Anita Hill came up with that I
thought you did a huge service actually
because as has been pointed out by
interminably now has happened to
innumerable women in the workplace you
know of course I must say my sister
wrote from England said if we haven't
been sexually harassed as children and
we've been furious sooner well there's
something to there and all it's all
depends has it on your point of view but
anyhow we weren't we weren't in the
workplace we were in the sort of
marriage market you might say more you
know
we expected leave it harass but the I
mean but as girls we weren't working in
offices or anything we were so
debutantes and that kind of thing well
anyway I think that the I think there's
hell huge upset caused by Anita Hill is
going to really cause a big difference
and a very positive thing for instance I
cuz I watched that riveted I really
couldn't stay away from I can't tell you
how many days I spent just glued to
television it would start early in the
morning and then my husband would come
home not having seen any of it and then
we'd watch the reruns
oh my horrible you never so fascinating
I'll never be more interested than
except possibly in the Watergate
hearings again no couldn't get away from
those and in the army McCarthy hearings
but so then when Professor Hill came on
I thought that one of the most
astonishingly moving bits of the helmet
was her supporters those four people
came to testify but you know that she'd
tell them this and so and they were
obviously people with no axe to grind at
all and they were I thought stunningly
good and then if I could that what was
his name the that terrible fella
yeah exactly holy mother I couldn't
believe how awful he was you know every
was so the whole thing with so many
slices of life that I thought was
fascinating
my name is Giovanni I'm running for the
Board of Supervisors in 92 kind of upset
me what you said in the beginning I
don't believe in censorship at all any
really kind of form only thing I'm
against is an organization called NAMBLA
which is a men boy love association
which of people are not doing and 40
year old men that are dating boys that
are 15 I don't agree that anyone under
the age of 16 should be photographed
nude unless of course it's for what you
call art now porno and art is totally
different
porno to me is something that is created
I was 14 years old and I had a lover
that was 37 I really was never able to
make the choice so that is why I am very
upset about what you said because there
is a difference to me I believe anybody
underneath the age of 16 should not be
photographed nude unless of course it's
for art that you're going to hang on the
wall no porno at all
well I don't care what you call porno in
other words um they I don't quite know
what you're driving at transsexual
intercourse between two boys and at 13
14 years old which is done in this
country and done in other places of this
world which is which is totally wrong
it's totally sick well I think that
people want to buy it then something's
wrong with
well I try to say before bars I think
that to coerce children into this whole
thing is obviously wrong and there are
laws against it and the people doing it
should then be prosecuted this has
nothing to do okay I'll be with there's
nothing to do now well I think that's I
don't think they should do it I think
that the in other words what just any
more than the actual commission of rape
let's say the real rape on in a movie
not just have not not the gamut ization
of rape but an actual one well then
obviously would or the actual mutilating
or beating up or something of a woman by
a man obviously that should be again is
against the law and should be against
the law visit to me has nothing to do
with the issue of pornography as you
know as should people be allowed to see
it that's it it's two different matters
I think
Jessica I'm with Californians against
censorship together we're a grassroots
organization that has been fighting this
battle for the last five years here in
the state of California I want to let
your audience know that we'll have
people outside afterwards with an anti
censorship petition and some materials
on the organization but I know how
difficult this battle has been for
people to even realize that it's going
on it's been going on for 15 years now
and I sometimes I feel like the little
Dutch boy with the finger in the dike
you know and it's it's going to be
overwhelming
I felt that somewhat of a sense of
optimism in the last year or so and I'm
wondering how you see this battle this
vast cultural war raging right now well
I think I mean what I think of the
status of the whole thing I think it's
very dangerous and I think it's getting
probably getting worse just like almost
everything in other words with them
reporters the Education president or
whatever he is you want to expect and no
I think that it's um it's a real danger
you know and I'm very pleased to know
about your organization I don't believe
I'd like to join it actually I'll give
you some material good yeah
hi miss Medford to consider another area
of censorship acts of violence I believe
in the latest movie latest version of
Arnold and latest variation on his
Terminator 2 right pair approximately
every 20 seconds somebody's either
well riddled with bullets or stabbed
with knives or Burton fire or at one
point I think the whole city of Los
Angeles explodes okay
yeah well they there may be those with
fevers however I'm here to stand I say
nothing against our southern brethren
either of Southern California or Alabama
as the case might be but I wondered that
I was in Norway once upon a time and I
remember watching a Clint Eastwood movie
I think was called the gauntlet and an
amazing thing kept happening every time
Clint had to face the bad guy or I
should say guys usually they some reason
I'll never understand by the Dozen would
attack him a split second later the
fight would be over and he'd be kind of
brushing his hands and on his way in
other words you never saw anybody shot
stabbed or pummeled with fists on the
other hand everything to do with the
body just as a form was exposed to view
of one and all even on Billboard's as I
recall anyway would you care to make any
comments on the validity of censoring
violence in movies I'm against centering
in any of that yeah really I mean again
obviously if actual violence is being
done you know for for the purpose of
filming as distinct from play-acting
violence you know which is what we see
on on the screen every real violence is
being done cause it should be the people
doing it should be prosecuted in the
ordinary way just as they would be if
they mugged you in the street but I
think that the the idea of sort of
trying to get you know the solve either
so much violence on the screen and it's
making is turning us into a violent
society I don't agree with that I don't
think it's true I mean I I you can just
turn it off if you don't like it that's
my view of it anyhow
hello I was just wondering if you had
heard of this case of a Dennis Priebus
it's on the east coast of the United
States this was in the papers many
months ago well was it Nick Dennis
Priebus he owned a video store and he
had a few videos that were declared
obscene
oh yeah and his entire store was taken
away from him over a million dollars
worth confiscated and he was sentenced
to prison for three years he could have
been sentenced to 10 years because of
the crazy laws that we have and it's not
well known that this even happened in
the United States and there are more
people being tried today and it's seems
ridiculous for people who commit murder
get out real quick now here's someone
who only had a few x-rated videos just
like many other thousands of stores and
here he is going to prison for three
years and he could have gotten 10 years
well that's it that's exactly the sort
of thing I think that this ad was
talking about about the censorship you
know whether it's rising or not and I
think it is I think that's an example of
a very dangerous sort of thing to be
happening but I think that this whole
idea of banning even banning violence
you know is hopeless I don't think it
doesn't it doesn't address what causes
violence since my point you know in
other words I don't think that watching
a violent scene on television or in the
movies is going to make somebody go out
and be violent the roots of violence are
different I believe and so that's why I
think that in fact you do you remember
the Meese Commission ed Meese oh god
that was a moment wasn't it
anyway the ed Meese um he assembled this
whole vast Commission who spent a year I
don't know how long and how much of
taxpayers money
seeing all the disgusting the sort of
sexy revolting pornography you know they
could possibly their parent lead or
doing it you know they'd have tremendous
time but in the end that that commission
which was specifically supposed to
discover the correlation between
pornography and violence was completely
unable to do so
which I thought was jolly interesting
and that's something that because there
they were so studying up on the whole
thing and trying to find it out and they
couldn't get anywhere with finding any
relationship between pornography as such
and violence and or rape and X against
women and that kind of thing yeah
instance for cultural which we've
inherited from our Puritan ancestors for
instance everybody's body has similar
aspects similar attributes and yet you
never see a picture of a woman on TV or
in a movie except that her breasts are
covered up every woman has breasts why
do we make a taboo of exhibiting fresh
hmm there are many cultures where
various aspects of the body are accepted
but we've inherited our cultural taboos
from our from our Puritan ancestors and
I don't think we'll ever get rid of them
well it's so difficult to tell I know
that where I come from England you don't
see very much in the way of breasts
they usually rather well color too damn
cold something set which is so very
crude dick I'd like to ask what if any
common agenda are the political or a
human impulse do you see between those
who would ban pornography on let us say
the left and those on the right and I
use pornography in their sense not in
any absolute sense the people who pass
the ordinance in Minneapolis yeah have
something in common politically and I
don't mean ideologically politically
with the people who are in the South
trying to to or Tipper Gore for instance
who wants who wants to avoid certain
lyrics in music is there a common theme
that you say well I think is that that's
the thing so kind of intriguing about
the position of the militant feminists
you know the fact that they're right in
bed with nice and all those people you
know it's very weird indeed I agree but
uh I I'm sure that they would probably
dispute having the same political agenda
in other ways but but on the other hand
what I mean how can they avoid being
linked up together it's weird actually
by the way nobody's mentioned this this
book psycho American Psycho which was
you know all in the news a few months
ago I guess again there was a great deal
talk but the you know that should be
banned and that kind of thing and again
I don't I mean from everything I've read
about it it sounds incredibly bad I mean
you know as far as writing and so so it
wouldn't stir me to want to read it
particularly but I'd be very much
opposed to any banning of it and so
there we come again soul full sack over
there
I'm concerned about the rise of
neo-nazism and fascism both in this
country and abroad and I'd like to know
how you feel about the issue of
censorship and how it relates to people
who are putting forward a blatantly
racist or fascist message yeah you mean
what kind of message you mean in other
words people who uh you mean racists a
blatant blatantly racist yeah white
supremacist fascist message
well I'm very much against all those I
can tell you to me that's a whole
different question and it has nothing to
do with them actually with sex in the
First Amendment Oh in fact doesn't have
to do with either in my view I think
that for instance I had a terrific
falling out with the American Civil
Liberties Union on this very matter when
some years ago the there was in the
state of Mississippi where I happened to
be for a while there was um the one
example I'm you know the ACLU is pretty
much an all-white organization there's
very very few black people's you go to
one of their meetings or banquets and
things it's pretty much all white
well the in Mississippi that wasn't true
there was a it was very integrated ACLU
and there were large number of blacks on
the board of it now the the Ku Klux Klan
announced plans to hold a rally in a
newly integrated grammar school I mean
you know grade school somewhere in the
Delta of Mississippi
so as usual they appeal to the ACLU to
sort protect them on this thing well the
there was a great girls or machination
that went on but what happened is that
the local ACLU which was as I said
they're about a third black and the
executive board was about half or third
that and they voted against completely
doing having anything to do with
supporting the Klan in its efforts to
have a rally in that school the national
office then went behind their back and
did give support to Eclair this is all
some time ago time the details rather
escaped me but I thought that that was
an outrage you know that the local board
wraps a tree right to try to prevent the
Klan from doing that I think it's
another another matter really
I'm sorry to the people in the middle of
syrup this is less of a question and
more sort of a response to your comments
I find your characterization of Andrea
Dworkin and especially Katherine
McKinnon's work kind of unfair
especially in the context of a large
group of what seem to be fairly liberal
people in that I think that it's
important to remember that MacKinnon is
responsible for for instance the legal
definition of sexual harassment in the
workplace and has in fact given American
women a lot of very important legal
tools to fight the battles that you know
we're continuing to fight and the
Minneapolis the Minneapolis ordinance is
very controversial you know and rightly
so but I think it's wrong to condemn the
body of her work in light of that one
example no I do I agree with you about
that was her name Katherine wicked
McKinnon yeah exactly
no I'm aware of that of her work on
sexual harassment I think I'm all in
favor of that she did a great job and I
don't mean to condemn her at all for
that it's just that I think that she and
Landrieu talkin were barking up a
completely wrong tree when they try to
get that ordinance you know well I think
again that's debatable I think maybe
their their approach well well no no but
I was interested in this gentleman's
question back here about how you see
their agenda allied with the agenda of
people on the far right you know in a
conscious way I mean they sort of end up
to be on the same engine spectrum on
this issue but you know on this issue
but I think it's an interesting question
that maybe hasn't been posed to them
publicly about whether or not they you
know how they would articulate the
differences in their well I caught I
think that is an interesting thing to
pursue I'd know way of doing it I wish
they were here and they could explain it
all you know
this is like at the ballpark repast two
dollars to get a beer
sorry they only have Phil Daniel yeah hi
this is more of a response I'm my name
is Cathy Daly and I work with the
American Civil Liberties Union and I
really enjoyed your presentation tonight
but I have to take disagreement with
your remarks about the ACLU I think that
it's wonderful you're talking about the
dangers of censorship but I know full
well having past experience the dangers
of censorship from the left as well as
the right and so I would ask that you
keep that in mind I know we'll never
agree on it but if we take away free
speech from one group it's going to be
taken away from all of us
I was just curious to know if your
forthcoming book deals at all with sex
in the First Amendment as it relates to
access to birth control and abortion
clinics and many of the issues that have
come up with the gag rule and so forth
that are pretty hot topics at this point
is that is that a part of your book or
do you know we should Paul's in a way
but mine is only going to be about the
it really is did you know just the stark
facts of having babies in America and
what happens and especially what a
little spectrum of the mechanization of
birth and that kind of thing you know
plus the the horrible fate of poor
people in this country and the need for
a total of all the health system that
kind of thing you know my favorite it's
not gonna be specifically not dealing
with the overriding important issue like
abortion because you know that's been so
yet another years work I'm afraid yeah
that's equally interesting I have one
more question I'm sorry one thing that I
work with as transvestites and
transsexuals and I need to know what
your viewpoint on that is and also what
kind of things if any of you put in your
book concern so you mentioned the south
and I've met Jerry Falwell face-to-face
many times in New York so I have been
beat up by the Republicans of freedom
and all this so I need to know what your
viewpoint on transsexualism is because
and that's a good I'm sorry if it's it
off the walk was I mad and I'm not sure
what means transsexualism does that mean
what does it mean in fact is it by sex
you know it's men who dresses women it's
what men as women called
yeah have you touched on I have you
hunched on and the censorship that
they're going through and that struggle
that they're going through especially
with Jerry Falwell in the fundamentalist
no I mean see I wish I knew more about
that because I just because I'd be on
the side of the transsexuals over there
very much sir I guess finally hug the
mic one more time
I think you've addressed the question of
politics and censorship but suppose
overnight a cabinet post was established
national censor and you miss Mitford
were appointed to it I'd love that
with full discretionary authority over
not not only arts and entertainment but
the news media and perhaps textbooks
what in your wildest fantasies and
imaginings might you do my god I wish
you'd sort of let's see you'll have give
me a little while to think that over if
we ever meet again but I'll try to have
an answer I think maybe it's time to
close up the meeting isn't it
well we thank all of you for joining us
this evening and we certainly thank you
for entertaining and educating us and we
would like to hope that the dialogue may
continue throughout San Francisco and
the public library would like to help
make that happen so thank you very much
and good evening